joining us now is green beret former
counterterrorism advisor to Vice
President Cheney Florida congressional
candidate Michael waltz is with us and
also with us retired CIA senior
intelligence officer sana brand policy
group vice president Danielle Hoffman
Danielle let's start with you I think
the most important thing in you're the
expert on Russia and all of this is the
president had talked about we're done in
Syria then this happens we know Assad is
use chemical weapons in the past I don't
think America can stand idly by when men
women and children are being gassed
question is was it Assad and his regime
or is it potentially the rebels in the
Civil War that want the United States to
stay there well the line that it's
that's the opposition launching these
sorts of attacks as a pretext so that
the United States would become involved
that's that's the Russian news media and
it's propaganda the truth is that the
Syrians have been lost we know that for
sure we would be able to make to tell
the difference we know Assad has 'm do
the rebels have these weapons so I from
my experience it has been the Assad
regime that has the capability to
deliver the weapons these are barrel
bombs that you need helicopters an
aircraft to deliver them and the rebels
don't have that capability it's the
Assad regime that has the chlorine and
the sarin gas to launch these attacks
and they control the security for these
area it's gonna be very difficult to
prove that any chemical weapons were
used because Assad's own security guys
are going to be shepherding around
according to the latest news reports
this these representatives from the
organization from the potential of
chemical weapons
Michael Walt's same question sir well
just to add to that point Sean we can
track these aircraft we tracked them
last time we know exactly what airbase
they come from and we know that this is
the Assad regime we also have the
ability to intercept communications but
to your point Sean this president
understands two things one in action has
consequences and and we are bearing now
the consequences and he's having to deal
with the inaction of the last eight
years under President Obama that's
allowed this problem to get this bad
and then number two that diplomacy is
actually benefited by the credible use
of military force sometimes you actually
have to employ that force and in this
case I hope and expect to see Syrian
pilots not have a single runway left
after hour standoff cruise missiles take
them out enough is enough we can parse
out the attacks away from Russian assets
where they put very sophisticated
Russian anti defence missile systems and
take down Assad's Air Force once and for
all all right guys we really appreciate
it will be watching obviously very very
closely